you know how this works well keep it  simple for an enemy combatant and will  not be granted any rights this won't go  anywhere welcome to hell  lockdown on this boat right away  the man's a highly decorated officer and  a trained killer he's been taught to  adapt improvise just find out I need you  to tell me what is going on right now  someone is sitting yeah  scented level of glands he'll I believe  we should get you one of these I knew I  liked you  and the old days it was just red wire  blue wire  [Music]  my name is Patrick Faris and the chief  author she was a Saudi I'd like to start  by making you aware that you are an  enemy combatant therefore have not and  will not be granted any monies you know  how this works so I'll keep it simple I  want the location of the drive along  with the names of those complicit in  your efforts to sell this wanna go in  your  and the old days it was just red wire  blue wire I knew I liked you  [Music]  you